I haven't really opened up about this
very often
giving us advice or trying to joke about
things doesn't always work because it's
such a sensitive issue it may have
started out as a choice but at that
point it was something that I wanted to
stop and couldn't stop eating disorders
are also a lot more mental than you
think they are it's less about
discipline than it is kind of a
compulsion people with eating disorders
look very different what I would want
people to know is that you don't have to
put yourself in my shoes really not
about vanity or rational decisions it's
just something you know is destructive
but you can't really stop I wish I could
say that there was this clear thing
where like I did this and then I got
better I compared it to addiction in
that way the only thing you have to
worry about is asking us how you can
help
I think body image with guys needs to be
a much more open conversation and
sometimes that just means listening
sometimes that just means all you can do
is let us handle things because that's
what's working for us right now